real quick really really disturbing news
from one of the most horrible
neoconservative war hawks and architects
of the 2003 Iraq war former Bush
administration official Paul Wolfowitz
who is the epitome of a neoconservative
extremist says Donald Trump is dangerous
and that it would be really bad if he
became president of the United States he
said in an interview published a few
days ago that I wish there were somebody
I could be comfortable voting for I
might have to vote for Hillary Clinton
even though I have big reservations
about her he says he admires Putin that
Saddam Hussein was killing terrorists
that the Chinese were impressive because
they were tough on Tiananmen Square that
is pretty disturbing the only way you
can be comfortable about Trump's foreign
policies to think he doesn't really mean
anything he says that's a pretty
uncomfortable place to be in this is
arguably one of the most prominent
neoconservatives and interventionists of
the last 15 years and Donald Trump is
too reckless for the guy who wanted the
United States to go to war in Iraq when
I see Wolfowitz talking about the 2016
election I see someone who support
nobody wants or should want anyway this
really shows us the scope and caliber of
exactly how dangerous even
neoconservative see Donald Trump is
being and I know some people email me
and say David this is not about
Wolfowitz being concerned about Trump
this is about Wolfowitz liking Hillary
because she's the neoconservative
Warhawk well if that's the case he's not
saying it because he's making very clear
that he's not comfortable with Hillary
Clinton it's just that Trump would be so
reckless that he might actually end up
voting for Hillary Clinton incredibly
disturbing incredibly damning this is
one of the worst political Warhawks of
the last 15 years and he's scared about
what Donald Trump might do as president
of the united states that is some
serious food for thought